les ruines fumaient encore au lever du
jour la dévastation aussi profonde que
le cratère creusé au sol par l'explosion
de la nuit dernière sous les décombres
les morts ils sont au moins huit un
bilan encore provisoire
des services de secours y ont passé la
nuit et une partie de la journée à la
recherche de survivants ce sont surtout
les morts qui l'ont extirpé des cendres
et des gravats cette fois la guerre
s'est rapproché du centre de kiev pour
les habitants du quartier de pau deal
densément peuplées c'est un choc
d'abord j'ai vu une énorme explosion
raconte dima puis le flash a illuminé ma
chambre je vis juste ici devant joe
poteau puissante explosion m'a jeté hors
de mon lit cette explosion la voici
captées par des caméras de sécurité près
du centre commercial riz trouville qui a
été en partie soufflée par la puissante
déflagration
nous aimons tous que c'est difficile
pour moi de parler parce que mon enfant
travail est ici dit valentina elle était
au travail hier et cette chose s'est
produite hier soir
l'avancée des forces russes autour de la
capitale semble figé depuis près d'une
semaine mais en revanche les tirs et les
bombardements us s'intensifie depuis 24
heures encore visiblement trop loin pour
des tirs d'artillerie l'armée russe s'en
remettent essentiellement aux frappes de
missiles et tirs de roquettes
une tactique qui sèment la terreur au
sein de la population accuse ou lan à
sopron elle et son mari avaient
brièvement succomber à la peur et
quitter kiev mais ils sont revenus
le couple a choisi de défier la tacc
russe en relançant leur travail
philanthropique depuis la capitale oulan
à qui est aussi américaine a été
ministre de la santé son mari marco un
canado ukrainien est journaliste et
activiste
une semaine
[Musique]
une autre mélodie qui le riz tous les
deux très familière vient interrompre
notre entretien soudainement le temps
s'arrête sur la place maïdan bercé par
un air qui accompagne beaucoup de jeunes
mariés pour leur première danse
[Musique]
des paroles qui aujourd'hui résonne
comme le serment de foi de tous les
ukrainiens
je vais rêver vivre maintenant porté par
les ailes de l'espoir
comment ne pas aimer kiev ma chérie ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada kiev